My name is Michael
Downey and I'm
the Community
Manager for OpenMRS.
We're a free and open source
medical record system,
primarily for use in
the developing world,
or anywhere people
have limited access
to IT and technical means.
So our students
this summer worked
on some really amazing projects.
We had everything going on from
redesigning the UI of OpenMRS
to be more accessible
and user friendly
for clinicians, people
working in hospitals.
We had people integrating with
other systems, such as business
intelligence systems, and
other health IT systems.
So people can take
health information
and share it freely among
many different free software
projects.
One of the really
interesting projects
that our student
worked on this summer
was building a
software development
kit, an SDK for OpenMRS,
which will really
open the doors for
many more Summer
of Code students,
many more volunteers
through the future
to get them up
and running as an
OpenMRS developer
literally in a
matter of minutes.
In the past it took
hours or even days
to get a development
environment set up.
And this student's
project has really
made it possible for people
to get involved very, very
quickly.
So OpenMRS got started
in the second year
of Google Summer of
Code back in 2006.
And I got involved with
the project in 2009
and have been an Organization
Administrator since then.
And basically that means
while I'm not a mentor myself,
I help coordinate all the
mentors and all the students
every year for the program.
And quite frankly, it's been
a really, really rewarding
experience to get to meet
students and mentors from all
over the world, and to make some
really awesome projects happen
each summer.
For me as an Organization
Admin for OpenMRS,
I really, really enjoy getting
to know all the students
and mentors from
around the world.
We have as many as 20 students
and mentors each summer.
And really am just energized
by the awesome projects
that they put together.
And to see them do real
work that's rewarding
is really educational
for the students
and a really great
experience for our mentors.
One of the most exciting
things about GSOC
is getting the
experience to meet
some of our students
and our mentors
and bringing them together.
We have annual and regular
user events and conferences
throughout the year.
And in more than
one instance, we've
had several generations
of mentors and students,
and students who turned
into mentors get together.
They've posed for
large group photos.
Get to meet each other in
person after so many hours
spent communicating
online and virtually.
To have them come together
really as a family
and get together has been
really touching to see.
And it has really served as an
inspiration for those students
to go forward and recruit new
students into the program.
In our GSOC program
for OpenMRS, we
have a tagline that's called
Write Code, Save Lives.
And that's really
meaningful to us
because the work that we do has
a direct impact on the quality
of health care people
receive in some
of the most neediest
areas of the world.
People without
access to good health
care, without access to
even good IT systems.
And so what that means is that
the students who work for us
have a direct opportunity to
improve the quality of life
of people sometimes in
their own countries,
sometimes neighboring countries.
But at the end of
the summer, they
know that they've done
something really concrete,
and have been able to really
save lives around the world.
So our goal is to save
the world essentially.
And GSOC has really been able
to give us the opportunity
to do that and to help
our students do that.
And so we're looking
forward to continuing
that mission in years to come.
OpenMRS is an electronic
medical record system platform.
And what that means is
we built an ecosystem
where people can add on
functionality to the system
and then pick and
choose what they
need for the type of health
care that they're doing.
So it may be used by something
from a random doctor traveling
through the villages
in Western Africa,
all the way up to a network of
connected hospitals and clinics
throughout the country.
So we have really
an entire scale
of users from the very
simple to the very complex.
And with Google Summer of Code,
it's possible for our students
to be involved in all of
those types of scenarios.
So there are many
different ways for people
to get involved in OpenMRS.
The easiest way is just
to go to openmrs.org,
click on Get Involved.
And you can choose
what type of interest
you have and we'll
help match you up
with mentors and projects
and tasks within our project
to really get
started right away.
We need everyone from people
who can do development work,
to project management or
infrastructure kind of work,
to graphic designers,
to documentation people.
Really no matter what
your interests are,
there's a place
for you in OpenMRS.